[Music]
shelly in atlanta what's up shelley
yeah right with jelly that's awesome
we're not even going there we're not but
shelley does run with kelly but you
already sound kinder than kelly so
what's up
all right so
last summer i was told that i am
arrogant
and
that was kind of a shock to me because
you may be more like kelly than we
thought so go ahead
so i tend to have problems with
self-loathing and perfectionism i hope
kelly does not have that problem
no she doesn't have a problem with it
she just knows that she is perfect so
that's good
so
my negative automatic conclusion was oh
no i'm not hating myself enough or i
wouldn't look arrogant
exact way to go way to
and i know that's not a healthy way to
think about it but
it's kind of been eating me alive ever
since then
because i don't want to be arrogant and
that's the last thing i ever thought i
was i tend to really not think i'm
better than other people
so who told who told you this
so
it was a work supervisor i
recently
um came out of an abusive marriage and
went to
interview for a new job in a new place
and
i understood that you know when you do a
job interview you're supposed to sell
yourself and
um
you know sort of exaggerate how good you
are and oh it's exaggerated but you just
killed it you those are one of the few
moments in our culture that we're
allowed to talk about ourselves
positively which is lame but that's
where we got so did you did you oversell
yourself or did you think you did a
great job
i felt like i did a good job i thought i
played the interview game well and i got
the job
but
the supervisor later was like you know
you're kind of arrogant
um based on that interview are based on
how you come into work every day and how
they experience you and here's what i'm
getting at two important things when
somebody says something like that to you
one is do they have credibility to speak
into your life
and if they don't then
just like jay-z you gotta brush your
shoulders off you gotta move on from
that i mean people are gonna there's
gonna be critics everywhere that's
that's life
if it's somebody that either a you need
them to
experience you in the right way someone
you love your spouse your parents
whatever
or your supervisor who
that your livelihood depends on them
being in relationship with you
um then that's a little bit more
important and so
there has to have been a series of
behaviors of actions that they
experienced what were they
well so it was literally just based on
the interview
um
because i am
a sign language interpreter so i often
work by myself or
only
with people sometimes it's not like i
see this person every day or anything
like that
so
it was
really just based on
the interview
okay
i thought i was a better interpreter
than everybody else
are you
no
and i know that and i don't think that
so
can you
i'm gonna i am going to
just shine my ignorance
brightly okay okay sure can you be
arrogant in sign language obviously your
words are but can you come across that
way
yes although the interview was in
english
okay so
hmm
something else is going on here because
that one comment has caused you to
spiral out for a year
is that the first time somebody's told
you that
or are you really thin skinned like what
is it about that comment
i think that
i
it really took me by surprise and
um
you know it was it also came on
the heels of
my husband leaving me because i'm a
christian and he became an atheist okay
um so and there was abuse going on um so
did your husband did this have does this
have
ghosts of your relationship with your
husband telling you things about you
that you need to change need to fix that
he doesn't like about you that reasons
that you're broken
criticism i mean i'm just trying i'm
fishing here yeah
i mean he would tell me things like
you're just good at making people feel
sorry for you i don't think
he thought i was arrogant he saw me go
into self-loathing a lot but i think it
just hit on
like that i'm a recovering perfectionist
and
that
anytime
someone says something about me i tend
to think it must be right and
and i have grown up as kind of the
the good child of the family and there
were
others of my generation that thought i
was stuck up or arrogant because i was
obedient okay so this is a lifelong
thing somebody rang one of your bells so
here's something that happened to me
several years ago a few universities
back where i worked
um
i applied for a job that i thought i was
a
or at least for a finalist position
and i didn't get an interview
which in that in my situation was a move
it was a statement
like i
like we're not even going to talk to you
about this
and so i i asked like man so i'm missing
something
and i thought i did good work i thought
i was a good guy
and
um
so a buddy of mine said man i'll ask
around and then he called and said hey
you wanna go to lunch it's my buddy mark
he called and said hey you wanna go to
lunch i said yeah
and um he said i'm gonna be honest with
you here's what i heard and
what came back
was devastating to me
and here's why i'm uncomfortable in
certain academic settings i've always
struggled with whether you're smart
enough that's why i keep going to grad
school to to prove myself to myself it's
ridiculous but that's me
and
i feel uncomfortable around really smart
people because i'm i'm intimidated by i
like being around them so much and i
love good engagement but
um i don't always fit at those in those
tables and i don't like
i'm uncomfortable in banquet kind of
situations
i love them when i'm there but just i
this takes a season to get it i got to
gear up for it
and so what i often do is i spend a lot
of time in the back of those rooms
meeting with the sitting with the
students or sitting with
um the police officers the security
officers or sitting with the custodial
staff
that's where a guy grew up my dad was a
police officer my dad would work
custodial stuff on the weekends like
it's just who i grew up
and
the feedback came back was you're a
slick politician
that you walk around the room and you
glad hand everybody and you always spend
your time trying to look like you're
with these people
and it was the exact opposite of what i
was
trying to do because i wasn't trying to
do anything other than be comfortable
and but the feedback was good and so i
had to make a decision number one am i
gonna stop being comfortable in my
professional life the answer is no
number two
is there some things that i took from
that feedback like hey here's how you
come across absolutely and he was right
he was absolutely right when i when he
explained how i walk into a room i was
like oh my gosh that guy looks like an
idiot and he's like well that guy's you
and so i took some wisdom from that
here's what i think about self-loathing
i think self-loathing
can be hitting the pendulum so far the
other way that you end up in the exact
same places on the other side of the
spectrum
you know what i mean like i
i want to follow the rules i want to be
a perfectionist hey you missed a rule
here
well
i must be the worst person ever which is
the same thing as i must be the best
person ever just on the other side of it
it's just living in these dramatic
swings
and you labeled yourself a bunch in this
call
and you live by these labels
and i want to see you live a life free
of labels
like shelly what do you want what do you
want in your world
what do i want yeah what do you want
you get one how old are you
30. 30. so you're 33 done
33
you're 33 done
and
in some statistical models you're about
halfway you're almost halfway done
depending so i like to just go on the
long end of that tail
you only get one of these
one
and it's tiny and it's quick and it's
precious
what do you want to do with it
i mean i would like to make a difference
in people's lives
that's external that's you fishing
what do you what do you want
to be happy and accepted i guess
to be loved who told you you couldn't be
loved
besides your ex-husband
probably myself
yes like
but i can't be loved if people think i'm
arrogant or
if people think
something about me that's not true it
automatically is true because they've
got it so here's what
i want you to do
when somebody drops that brick in your
backpack someone tells you something
about you
you're not pretty enough you're too big
you're too skinny you're too this you're
too jesusy you're not jesus enough
you're you swear too much you're such a
goody goody with your language whatever
it is
you're arrogant because of an interview
where you told everybody you flexed a
little bit good for you you told
everybody i'm i'm a incredible um
sign language
doer i don't know how to use interpreter
interpreter
i can rock it on to the break of dawn
when it comes to sign language everybody
better recognize and get in line behind
shelly
shelley jelly and
they said hey you came across as
arrogant i want here's what i want you
to do
keep a small journal go to walmart or
target or if you're an overbuyer overbuy
it
and have a small journal and it's just
your story journal and carry it with you
everywhere i have a small one in my bag
right now
and
when somebody says dude you're arrogant
or you're a jerk or you are filling the
blank
or when those thoughts pop in your head
about you
i want you just to write it down
and
extend it out arm's length physically
and ask yourself is this true
and if it's not
you have to then decide i'm gonna stop
dwelling on it you don't make that
decision you let your mind
control you
and i want you to take back control of
your thoughts
so how do i know if i'm arrogant
are you
i mean i
i
value myself and i don't know i'm
valuing myself as arrogant
do you have somebody that you trust
do you have a friend a community
some yeah
ask them
so i did ask my sister what she said and
she
she said
um she said i know that you
have some insecurities and so i know
where that comes from it can look
arrogant but i know
like in your heart it's not so when she
says look arrogant what are the things
that look arrogant
like
um
are you mean to people do you talk do
you cut in a line do you say oh my gosh
i'm so much better than that than you
look at my body compared to yours my bag
is nicer than your but i mean
here's here's what here's the here's the
challenge these thoughts swirl around
and they're hard to grab onto and they
spin faster and faster and then
you start looking for confirmation of
them everywhere and you'll find it
and somebody will look at you a little
bit weird and you'll go oh it's cause
i'm arrogant or somebody will say oh
excuse me ma'am and you'll go oh they
think i'm arrogant you'll see it
everywhere
and that's why i want you to write it
down and get some distance from it and
then begin to pull it apart what are the
things is it how i stand is it how i am
rude do i talk sharp with people does my
voice get loud what are the details of
this thing that we can work on
mine was i walked in and shook hands in
a particular order throughout a room i
looked exactly like a slick politician
and it grossed me out
so one of the things i stopped doing was
shaking hands i don't like
i just stopped shaking hands and i
walked by and i look people in the eye
and say dude what is up and i stopped
trying to like be a professional engager
and i just started being a human engager
and it literally went away
and so there was some behavior things
that i could fix i didn't change who i
hung out with in a room i didn't change
how i honored the president of that was
in that room and the custodial staff in
that room all that stayed the same but i
did stop going from person to person and
shaking hands and nodding my head like a
tv politician and so there was some
actual things i could do that were
different that's what i'm asking you
what are the things people point to
i don't think they've really pointed to
anything just maybe the way
i talk that's a thing that's the thing
that's an action yes okay so the way you
talk
so like in the interview you know i
would say things like um
i think they talked about how they're so
so busy and don't have enough people to
handle it and i was like so you all need
me
or um
you know they were like
you know i told them some of the
experience that i had that was not
expected
that like they wouldn't have thought i
had that experience
as a young interpreter and they took
that to mean that i was arrogant
gotcha well so here's the deal you can't
control what they think
you control how you live
and so from this point forward when you
hang up the phone here
if you're not an arrogant person we're
done with the conversation and
begin being conscious about
kindness and leaning into people now
that you've got this job
love people and by the way
if they need you say that i
you see what i'm saying like i i don't
hear anything arrogant here i hear
somebody who is so
so incredibly tied to what the words
that come out other people's mouths for
her own security
that you will just spin and flip and
flop and do whatever it takes
for the per the next person in front of
you to value you
and what i want you to do is to get past
all of that and you begin to value you
and then you speak your truth out loud
and there will be certain people that
don't want to be around that truth and
that's okay they get to choose that
and there will be certain people that
gravitate towards that truth and it will
be incredible
but until you decide
i'm shelley and i
i am i'm worthy of my space
i am worthy of my jokes
i think these things are funny and i
think these are not funny and i'm okay
with that and i've got these opinions
and i'm willing to be wrong until you
can start to root yourself in the ground
there
you're just gonna have what you're
experiencing now one person's gonna say
one thing and it will spin you up for a
year it'll take up a year's worth of
thought real estate in your mind
and
it will mess with your biochemistry it
will make you live less long
because it will poison you every time
you talk to this person your heart's
going to start beating a little faster
and you can dump a little bit more
cortisol and adrenaline in in your
bloodstream it's going to slowly eat
your insides
but yeah i mean it's become kind of a
lens of like oh man i want to draw a
boundary here but i can't because
they'll interpret it as me being
arrogant and you can't control other
people
all you can control is your thoughts and
your actions
and
you can draw really firm boundaries with
kindness
and you can draw really firm boundaries
with joy people who
don't have strong internal sense of who
they are
they have to they often overcompensate
their boundaries they wait till it
builds and builds and builds and they
kind of explode on people
and then people go whoa
instead of the slow
regular
gentle making a boundary
hey can you do this yeah i can do that
can you do this yeah i can do that can
you do this no i need a weekend whoa
chill out
versus hey can you do this i'm out this
weekend but i would love to get to it
next monday i'd love to
that's a that's a boundary making
one small boundary at a time
and all of that comes back to do you
think you're even worth your own
boundaries
do you think you're worth saying no
do you think you're saying yes
do you think you're a person of kindness
sit down with somebody that you trust
and say let's look at these behaviors
how do i interact i want people when
they
interact with me i want them to come
away feeling
joyful i want them to come away feeling
like i'm a little bit happy after
talking to that person
that's what i want so let's work on
those actions and your heart may never
change here because your heart's
probably good
but your heart has to be plugged into
you
and you got to be okay with you and
you're not
and that's where i want you to start
writing down on a piece of paper
what do i want and let's backfill it how
do we get there